7h30 ce matin le chargement de la
camionnette se termine dans le dépôt
départemental des restos du coeur
le concept est nouveau dans le doubs
grâce à ce véhicule
l'association va desservir trois
nouveaux bourg des zones blanches ignoré
jusque là entre deux centres de
distribution permanent on s'est aperçus
qu'à des gens qui avaient besoin des
restos du coeur qui a des difficultés
alimentaires qui venaient pas en restant
dans ces zones là justement parce que
c'était trop loin de distribution il ya
beaucoup de raisons qui font que les
gens viennent député gens viennent pas
une des raisons c'est l'éloignement des
centres de distribution et à rougement
la distribution est organisée dans ce
local attenant au gymnase est mise à
disposition par la mairie
elle a lieu tous les mardis matins
depuis trois semaines seulement chacun
doit prendre ses repères mais d'ores et
déjà les premiers bénéficiaires sont
satisfaits s'il ya plus tracing un
mouvement pour nous c'est plus facile
parce que moi ya pas de moyen de
locomotion
avant vous alliez un bond énorme oui
appuyé des restos du coeur qui s'enfonce
dans les zones rurales là où tous les
indicateurs montrent une augmentation de
la précarité logement
saint-hippolyte et arc-et-senans dans un
premier temps deux autres lieux
itinérant seront desservies ensuite le
système destiné reste est inhérent est
censée fusionner tous les jours la
semaine et 5 jan aps la semaine donc on
a pour l'instant coûté 3 forte
il en reste deux à mettre au point bon
on a voulu démarrer et tester les gens
les trois premiers 106,3 centre là avant
de passer à l'étape et définitive fin de
matinée la camionnette repart vers le
centre de stockage départementale elle
sera de nouveau à rougemont dans une
semaine